it's austin both in his first career
start against
the american league club made a career
high eight starts last year get this
right handers hit just 165 against him
stay in there and get the called strike
austin both with a one two three he's
been very very steady he's a guy that'll
give you 150 to 175 80 innings a season
last year 165 with the reds and the
athletics 2-2 to kendrick
[Applause]
fly ball right center field and a
playable shy of the track for t
oscar hernandez and tana rohar has
himself a one two three first i think
this is a good matchup for
vlady but i think tonight he's got a
chance to have a good night
1-1 from both in a breaking ball hit
high in the air left center field
[Applause]
the outfielders collide and where's the
ball
is it out the ball is out it's a home
run for vladimir guerrero jr
as bonifacio and robles collided neither
one could come up with a baseball looked
like bonifacio thought he might have had
it for a moment
but it winds up over the fence for
vladi's first home run
of the year yeah
robust is a terrific outfit or center
fielder and it looked like bonifacio
had a shot at it but guerrero hits it
into the bullpen in left field first
long ball of the season for glady
won one derisa maguire the catcher the
shift
turner a long way to his right strong
arm howie did he stay on
he did says manny gonzalez the first
base umpire
and neither mark baczinski the coach or
the runner maguire
argue that call
oh he's doing the superman here trey got
the
the backhand play set he knew how to
catch her running so he could take his
time but i think that ball might have
cut
look at the rotation on it almost
spiraling like a football
yeah 26 double seven triples five homers
36 rbis and he stole
40 bases he would cause havoc when he
got on base
roar and a hard line drive right side
that's a fair ball headed down the line
and toward the corner
chasing over there is biggio along the
side wall turner will coast into second
with a two out double
so an inside out swing and he shoots a
double down the right field line
adam eaton one nothing blue jays tying
run at second here comes the 2-0
swinging a ground ball right side that's
a base hit into right field it will tie
the ball game headed toward the plate is
trey turner
biggio will just lob it in towards
second adam eaton picks up his second
rbi with a game tying single
and it's the nationals one and the blue
jays won
a two-out rally with a turner double
driven home by adam
as lourdes gorilla junior comes to the
plate is one to guriel swung on and
hitting the air to center field hit well
back goes roblox he turns he looks it's
gone
lourdes goriel jr puts a charge into
that one
and it lands about eight rows up in dead
center field
lourdes with his first home run of the
season
the blue jays take a 2-1 lead six
out of the seven home runs hit by the
blue jays this season have happened
in washington four last night already a
pair
pop tonight you got to be your own
adrenaline you got to be your own fan
right now
[Applause]
pretty good damage there turner bare
hand is only chance
and he's going to make the play retiring
brandon jury
that was a great play a sneaky great
play wait to see the replay of this that
ball had so much english on it it hopped
back toward third base
so trey was coming straight for the
baseball the ball actually
checked up went toward third base he had
to make a last-minute adjustment and
bare-handed watch where this ball goes
whoops make that adjustment bare hand
across his body that's a sneaky awesome
play by trey turner
uj's catch a break and against tayasuka
hernandez to the plate
and he lines the ball into left field
for a base hit panic is coming around
third heading home and will score
without a throw
as the blue jays capitalize and extend
the lead
well what a big hit for the blue jays
take advantage of that castro heir and
hernandez didn't waste any time
he jumped on the first pitch and picks
up the rbi
he stayed back on the slider and rips it
into the left center
tanner rohart disqualified for a victory
in his first go around
as a blue jay rohar threw 73 pitches
tonight 47 for strikes allowing one run
over five frames on just a couple of
hits
roars settled down and retired the final
seven that he faced they're gonna let
will harris
pitch to rowdy to les here with the
bases loaded and two out
hernandez the lead at third bizio at
second guerrero at first
oh and two on rowdy and here it comes
and it's swung on and lined into right
center of base hit
into score is tay oscar biggio gets the
wave
he'll score as well to third guerrero
a two-run single for rowdy teles and the
blue jays take a
5-1 lead
an 0-2 pitch rowdy puts a heck of a
swing on it
and the blue jays do get that cushion
that they so
dearly need good time for your first big
league hit right here
well hit ball and he's got his first big
league base hit
and mark budzinski already asking for
the baseball
that is terrific
espinal is a terrific young man and look
at howard kendrick he's got a great
smile a ton of bass hits uh he's happy
for a kid to get his first big league
hit right here
and he got him swinging a miss to get
cabrera and the blue jays
finish off the nationals by a score of
5-1